hello and welcome to feed bakula the
show that listens to what our users have
been saying then takes the piss out of
them because they're largely talking
drivel what are they gonna do cancel the
show this week infamous second son
Sucker Punch's latest powered adventure
got reviewed by Tom mcshay this week he
gave the ps4 exclusive eight out of ten
ask or the internet saw as an open
invitation to start squabbling over
numbers irritating protagonists and
weirdly enough titanfall fact Tom hate
Feeney acts I can't be the only one
feeling underwhelmed but these graphics
I mean seriously this is next-gen it's
sort of like ten percent better than
last gen y yu do dis solid review can't
wait to get my copy times are hard for
the xbox now they're dancing in the
streets and doing backflips because
infamous SS got an a that's a good
school well congratulations on your
petty victory experts being playing a
while now and I have to agree with the
review so far it's definitely not as
good as I was hoping it's okay but
doesn't feel very next gen to me pretty
sure they could have released a watered
down version for ps3 looks great I can't
wait to give it a playthrough first
however dark souls 2 okay buddy see you
in about 200 hours titanfall few game
modes no private groups uninteresting
and forgettable story equals 9 infamous
second son questionable plot moments
equals 8 this industry right before we
throw the whole games industry into the
sea can we just take one minute to
acknowledge titanfall and infamous
second son a completely radically
different games a lot of people are
trying to squeeze a value judgment out
of two things that don't really belong
next to one another which is stupid here
Watch table has legs can support things
doesn't eat much eight out of ten goat
has legs will eat anything smells a bit
funny makes
nice cheese nine out of ten Oh rage is
not a meat of eight is this game dot dot
dot bracket bracket bracket the game is
a high-level dot dot dot next generation
is start for now in PS far you see
someone gets it I think I'm just a bit
confused is the compulsion to compare a
first-person online shooter to a
third-person single player action game a
direct result of tedious ongoing console
wars or if people just taken leave of
their critical faculties assuming they
had any to begin with Johnny Oh what are
they gonna do cancel the show so yeah it
was sort of business as usual in the
comments section for the M from the
second son review and by business as
usual I mean the conversation very
quickly and very violently veered away
from a consideration of the games
quality descending instead to arbitrary
comparisons and petty attempts at point
scoring not that I'm saying it wasn't
entertaining some of it was of a
professional standard like this gem for
instance whoa boy am I glad I bought the
xbox one ps4 is killer app haha flops
back to playing the best shooter in
years titanfall eat it cows okay class
let's have a look at this one in a bit
more detail shall we as you can see our
commenter in a truly committed attempt
to validate his recent cash expenditure
has decided to equate the number eight a
rating that defines a game as great as
being a failure he then follows this
rather skewed assertion by invoking
titanfall a completely different game by
aligning himself with a separate
critically acclaimed release he then
attempts to make its successes his own a
point he brings home by closing with eat
it cows when we examine all this
evidence in conjunction with the fact
the comment was posted with the username
ps4 has no games we are left with no
other conclusion than the commenter was
trying just a little bit too hard and
that it would be in the best interests
of everybody concerned if that person
never ever procreated Oh what are they
gonna do cancel the show oh
[ __ ] yes almost it from me just time for
a quick announcement q self-indulgent
sad music please friends after a couple
of years and a crapload of episodes feed
bakula is coming to an end it's been a
lot of fun at times it's made me want to
tear my beard out hair by hair but it's
simply time to let it go next week's
episode of feedback killer will be the
last one will be sending off the show in
style exact style to be confirmed
currently I'm gunning for Viking funeral
pyre but apparently that's not conducive
to a safe working environment by